channel letters are three-dimensional
and really stand out from the rest the
illuminated signs grab people's
attention and convert them into
potential customers channel letters are
made from acrylic the factory uses
colored vinyl to tint them an employee
peels the liner from the vinyl exposing
the adhesive backing he uses a roller to
apply the vinyl to one side of the clear
acrylic the other side of the acrylic
sheet is covered with a paper liner a
computerized router cuts the letters out
on that side
the font style and size are custom-made
for the client
after the letters are cut out they've
removed the paper vacuum
the employees use nails to hold the
letters in place as they work
the worker unrolls plastic trim cap and
cuts it to fit around the letter
he lives the letter with trim and
hammers and more nails to keep
everything in place
he makes cuts to the trim to form neat
corners the trim cap gives the letter a
finished look it also creates a surface
for attaching the back letter enclosure
called the letter can
he seals the trim around the entire
length with high-strength glue once it
dries he removes the nails now it's
ready for the letter can to make the
sides of the letter can they feed a wide
strip of aluminum into a computerized
machine it bends the aluminum to match
the face of the letter
it also forms a lip at the bottom to
attach the can to the back wall the side
of each channel letter is called the
return it attaches the letter face to
the back wall the return also creates
the channel which holds the lighting and
directs the illumination these are the
dyes that cut and shape the aluminum
using a computerized machine it takes
the worker a few minutes to create the
channel letter return it would take four
times longer to make the letter return
by hand here is a completed channel
letter returned with the ends welded
together
an employee slides the side structure
over the back wall to form the letter
can he checks the fit then clinches the
back to the return this completes the
channel letter can
they run LED lights throughout the can
in recent years LED lights have replaced
neon tubes because they are more
energy-efficient
an employee paints the aluminum can to
match the vinyl on the letters acrylic
front they test the lights if they were
the technicians mount the letter can to
the sign backdrop the Installer attaches
the translucent acrylic face to the can
it takes about an hour to make one
channel letter and a couple of days to
make an entire channel sign the final
product is sure to be noticed